[Music]
on this Sunday night the deadly mass
shooting in Nova Scotia for 12 hours
a gunman disguised as a Mountie
terrorized the community this is one of
the most senseless acts of violence in
our provinces history several people
killed including a member of the RCMP
tonight what we're learning about the
accused gunman planning for a pandemic
exit
yep the curb continues we would be able
to look at bringing kids back to
classrooms the strategy to slowly but
surely get Canada back on track plus the
outbreak at an Alberta oil sands camp
sparks concerns the virus will spread
unless there's rapid testing
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight with breaking news
out of nova scotia
where a gunman went on a shooting
rampage right now police say 14 people
are dead including the suspect the
community is in shock and the Mounties
are grieving the loss of one of their
own
constable Heidi Stevenson two children
have lost their mother and a husband has
lost his wife
parents have lost their daughter and
countless others lost an incredible
friend and colleague police were first
alerted to shots being fired at a home
last night that's where they found
multiple victims
the gunman then apparently went to other
houses in the area some were set on fire
and tonight we are learning the suspect
was wearing what appeared to be an RCMP
uniform and was driving what looked like
a police car but he was no Mountie our
coverage begins with Ross Lord a trail
of berto vehicles and houses are just
some of the grisly evidence of a
shocking rampage that started overnight
and continued for almost 13 hours along
a stretch of small Nova Scotia villages
we worried all night not knowing what
was going on with the police presence
and the fires with no fire trucks just
before midnight
RCMP tweeted they were responding to a
firearms complaint in the tiny village
of Porter peck about an hour-and-a-half
drive from Halifax they told the public
to stay in their homes with doors locked
eight hours later RCMP said they remain
on scene in an active shooter
investigation repeating the order for
residents to stay inside and locked
their doors they then identified the
suspect as 51 year old Gabriel Wortman
and that there were several victims by
late morning they tweeted Wortman may be
driving what appears to be in RCMP
vehicle and wearing in our CMP uniform a
short time later they reported Wortman
was driving a small SUV traveling
southbound on the trans-canada highway
after clarifying their suspect was not a
member of the RCMP they announced they'd
taken him into custody
in fact Wortman is dead he died after a
confrontation with police at a gas
station near the trans-canada at one
point during the course of the evening
hours he he appears to have been wearing
if not all in a portion of a police
uniform and that we believe that he was
dry while he was driving at one point a
mock-up or a vehicle that was made to
look like an RCMP police cruiser RCMP
say his murder spree left multiple
people dead including a female RCMP
officer a male officer was shot and
drove himself to hospital we are all in
shock that such a thing could happen
here in Nova Scotia and is a heavy
burden to bury on top of kovat 19 my
hearts go out to everyone affected in
what is a terrible situation I want to
thank the police for their hard work and
people for cooperating with authorities
Wortman was a denturist he worked out of
this office in Dartmouth Nova Scotia
sources say he owned property at Port
'epic beach although he was not
well-known among people who lived there
my sister knew him because he's
adventurous she just had new teeth made
by own and she thought he was the earth
a big question what changed that forced
people to cower in their homes all night
hiding from a killer your lock down in
your own little house and yeah it's
pretty scary
there's something you know it's not
going to happen here but it happens
they took hours for the RCMP to say that
14 people have been killed including the
suspect they had to retrace the suspects
every move they had to see what other
crime scenes there might be in other
communities before coming out with that
increased death toll Robin
Ross lured in Halifax thanks Ross we
continue our team coverage with Mercedes
Stevenson who has been talking to the
head of the RCMP Commissioner Brenda
lucky Mercedes what was her response to
the suspect having a uniform on a car
that looked like it was police issue
well Robin like everyone else she was
astounded by how authentic the car
looked she told me that she didn't think
that she would have been able to tell
what that car was and that it wasn't
real if she saw it on the street
and I've heard that from a lot of RCMP
officers who've taken a look at the
picture that it looked extremely
realistic she said that she's absolutely
stunned and deeply saddened by what has
happened I asked her if she's ever seen
an incident like this before in her
career and this is what she told me
personally I have not and I hope to god
I never see another one just a senseless
type of event like this where innocent
people are being killed there's just no
words to describe it at this time it
really is a stunning case what about
where this investigation is at now and
the possibility there could be more
victims what Robin right now they are
out scouring the various scenes looking
for more the Commissioner told me that
they are looking at vehicles at multiple
properties trying to figure out if there
might be more victims in this really
unprecedented case for Canada we spoke a
little bit about what the investigation
looks like and this is what she told me
it's just an extremely dynamic situation
that covers a large area with multiple
scenes buildings vehicles so there's
going to be a lot of work ahead of us to
get some answers now Robin a lot of
people are asking what is the motive in
this case and right now we don't know
and neither do the police commissioner
or lucky says that they're still trying
to figure out what happened at this
point they believe there's possibility
that this started with one motive and at
some point shifted into something more
random but they really don't know
they're trying to get as much
information about this man as they can
they will comb through his computers his
social media any information that they
can get but still everyone in shock how
realistic his uniform and car looked and
questions about that whether or not that
may have aided him as he was on the run
from police but certainly police all
across the country are absolutely
reeling with us tonight
Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thanks
Mercedes now to our other top story the
Cova 19 crisis let's take a look at the
picture across the country today more
than 1,500 people in Canada
died of copán 19 the number of confirmed
cases has now surpassed 34,000 more than
550,000 Canadians have been tested for
the virus the Canadian government is
considering how to kick-start the
economy it's a difficult balance because
of fears of a second wave of the virus
the Prime Minister says Canada won't
reopen overnight and that it's up to
each province already provincial leaders
are beginning to plan how best to come
out of the pandemic here's Jeff sample
with what Canada's exit strategy could
look like I just feel like am in limbo
Melissa Turner was planning to get
married at the end of July but now isn't
sure whether they'll need to postpone if
we're allowed to stay have a small
gathering I'm thinking to me small as
say maybe 15 20 people but like it's
pretty small I'm thinking but that might
not be small enough for over a month
Canadians have been keeping their
distance to slow the spread of kovat 19
and those efforts are paying off well
not out of the woods yet but it looks
like what we're seeing here is a bit of
a slow swell so I'm feeling a lot more
encouraged than I was feeling safe two
weeks ago sparking questions about how
long this lockdown will last many of the
decisions around what makes sense in
terms of a careful restarting of the
economy are much more appropriately made
at the provincial level and some
provinces are faring better than others
British Columbia and Alberta are
flattening their curves faster with
fewer new cases compared to Ontario and
Quebec officials in BC and New Brunswick
have suggested they might start lifting
some restrictions next month if the the
curb continues we would be able to look
at bringing kids back to classrooms
internationally some countries are
already relaxing restrictions thousands
of shops just reopened in Austria their
customers required to wear masks and
practice social distancing if there's no
new spike in cases here more businesses
will be allowed to open in two weeks you
know small businesses first businesses
that don't require a lot of people a
small area I
we're gonna start to see that here in
Canada as well in probably mid-may some
companies plan to implement mandatory
protective equipment and temperature
checks for employees so paramount number
one is making sure that when we come
back to work that we're coming back to
work safely countries including Canada
are scrambling to increase testing and
contact tracing capabilities because
even as the outbreak slows the vast
majority of the population remains
vulnerable to the virus and health
experts warn that loosening the taps on
the economy too quickly risks opening
the floodgates to a second wave of kovat
19 cases Robin Jeff sample in Toronto
thanks Jeff a copepod 19 outbreak at an
Alberta oil sands camp appears to be
spreading the company confirms there are
at least 18 active cases of Cova 19 at
the Kerr Lake mining operation which is
located about 70 kilometers north of
Fort McMurray in Alberta it's a 24-hour
operation workers fly in and out for
work now those returning to other
provinces for time off are being told to
isolate for 14 days
Heather York's West reports hundreds of
people come to work at Alberta's curl
Lake oil sands camp now it seems a
growing number of those workers have
also brought the new coronavirus home
Imperial the company that operates the
site has confirmed that there are now 18
cases of kovat 19 connected to the camp
four on site and 14 others who have
already returned home unfortunately you
know I think that this would happen that
we would start to see cases anywhere
where there is work happening in close
quarters complicating this outbreak is
the fact that workers fly in and out of
the camp from across the country on
Saturday the Saskatchewan Health
Authority directed any returning workers
self isolate for 14 days BC health
officials are also watching this
outbreak closely we do know that there
have been some people who have returned
home to British Columbia who were
exposed potentially in Alberta and
vice-versa and they are being monitored
isolating being monitored by Public
Health a memo posted to the app on
Friday April 17th tells employees there
is no need to self isolate if you do not
display symptoms and have not been
directed to by Alberta Health Services
through contact tracing
but infectious disease specialist dr. R
Neetu Singh doesn't believe that
Direction goes far enough given what we
now know about how this virus spreads I
think that it would be prudent at this
point for everyone who has been in a
camp where there have been documented
cases to self isolate for the 14 days
Imperial says its guidance is in line
with direction from Alberta health
officials but Alberta Health Services
says any worker returning home from a
camp with an outbreak should isolate for
14 days testing will also be available
for all workers at the curl lake camp
this week I think you have to remember
that the test is only a snippet in time
and people can be incubating the virus
and have a negative test but then be
positive later on but dr. Berger says
combined with extensive contact tracing
and isolation measures the extra tests
should help officials get this outbreak
under control Heather your exbest Global
News Calgary in an effort to set an
example of social distancing the
Liberals have reached a tentative deal
with the NDP and blockade equi to reopen
Parliament it would see a limited number
of MPs meet in Ottawa on Wednesday the
following week a 90-minute virtual
session would be added to the schedule
to allow MPs to ask the government
questions in May there would be three
sessions a week two virtual and one in
person but the Conservatives reject the
deal and are calling for three in-person
sittings I remain hopeful that the
government will agree to our
common-sense proposal to continue to
hold in-person sittings it has to be
done in a responsible way and right now
the Conservatives are not taking a
responsible approach if all parties
don't reach an agreement before tomorrow
the House of Commons will resume Monday
in person coming up why the governors
and the government in DC
can't get along Donald Trump is pushing
to have American businesses reopen soon
even as the number of cases of Kovan 19
climbs in the u.s. more than 760
thousand Americans have tested positive
for the virus at least 40,000 have died
now two states will be getting back to
business to morale but as Jennifer
Johnson explains there's concern the
move may end up costing more Americans
their lives the governor of Texas
feeling the heat and now bowing to
pressure from the White House and
constituents his state along with
Vermont will be the first to begin
reopening some businesses Monday while
still requiring social distancing u.s.
president Donald Trump promising there
are enough Kovan 19 tests to begin phase
one of reopening the country we have
tremendous capacity but governors from
both parties tell a different story
that's just delusional to be making
statements like that it's just
irresponsible because we're not there
yet to try to push this off to say that
the governors have plenty of testing and
they should just get to work on testing
somehow we aren't doing our job it's
just absolutely false
the White House push comes as a new NBC
news/wall Street Journal poll shows 58
percent of registered voters worry the
US will loosen stay-at-home orders too
quickly causing more deaths while 32
percent worry the US will take too long
harming the economy as unemployment
rates continue to skyrocket
White House officials are now promising
more emergency funds this week to help
small businesses decimated by the
pandemic after the first 350 billion
dollars to help those businesses ran out
within minutes because of that we want
Congress to approve more funds right
away we think that another 300 billion
dollars that's what we're talking about
should be sufficient to reach almost
everybody relief for small businesses
coming as millions of out-of-work
Americans struggle to put food on the
table food bank seeing more people than
ever before this is a blessing you know
we can use we have a five keys and then
like three grandbabies at home so right
now you know it's a big help to us
meanwhile some signs of hope in the
hardest hit States New York reporting a
drop in hospitalization rates as that
state along with New Jersey and
Connecticut reopened boat yards and
marinas in Washington a Seattle farmers
market is back in business with a
hand-washing station and time limits for
shoppers small steps in getting back to
normal before this pandemic shut the
country down Thank You Jennifer Johnson
Global News Washington still ahead
pandemic propaganda how Russia may be
spinning the crisis in its favor
it's being labeled From Russia With Love
a huge operation to send much-needed
medical assistants to places hit hardest
by the Cova 19 pandemic but tonight
there are questions about Moscow's
motives as Redmond Shannon reports some
say it's a smokescreen fueling
propaganda during the pandemic too many
we're not there on time when Italy
needed a helping hand at the very
beginning the European Commission
President apologizing for Europe's slow
response to Italy's Pleiss the EU has
since helped Italy but much attention
has focused on the Russian equipment and
soldiers on the ground in the country
for the past three weeks at least 100
experts and military medics according to
the Kremlin we really don't know very
much about the operation itself it's
it's it's rather secretive actually the
mission called From Russia With Love was
launched despite Russia's own struggles
in dealing with covert 19 at home it's
led by Major General Sergei ki khat
known for claiming that no chemical
weapons were used against Syrian people
in the 2018 duma attack it's a
large-scale PR propaganda operation to
kind of underscore this kind of message
that Italy is not getting help from its
European allies and from its
transatlantic allies and from NATO given
concerns about the risk of intelligence
gathering it's uncertain quiet Illya
loud Russian troops on the ground but
this Italian businessman was keen to
show where his gratitude lies and even
amid arguments over how useful the
donated equipment is pro-kremlin media
have lapped up the welcomes it's not
really false information it's spin it's
propaganda it's a kind of message to
shape perceptions but there has been
fake news too and China might be at the
center of that China has certainly
generously sent help to Italy and other
countries
[Music]
but this video was tweeted out by a
Beijing official it supposedly showed
Italians applauding the Chinese anthem
when in fact it's a doctored video of
Italians cheering their own health care
workers the Chinese embassy in Paris has
even been accused of spreading fake news
about deaths at a French nursing home
Russia and China both seem to want very
different things out of this crisis but
they're going about getting them in
exactly the same way now China of course
wants to deflect any blame for its early
handling of the spread of the virus
amid the horror and tragedy propaganda
and spin are swirling in every direction
a war for hearts and minds as the world
is on its knees Redman Shannon Global
News London up next how this Toronto
couple found a way to sustain the line
during the covert 19 crisis
the pandemic is bringing out some of the
best in people
and tonight we want to introduce you to
the Canadians doing their part to help
out Abigail Beeman joins us now abigail
you've been speaking with some
compelling people Robin there are so
many Canadians feeling anxious right now
facing challenges of all kinds health
financial social and it's so impressed
me to connect with some people who
despite facing those things are using
this time to give back and help others I
want to introduce you to a Toronto
couple restaurant owners who amid the
stress of figuring out how to revamp to
a delivery model and help they're laid
off staff access II I were committed to
figure out how to donate meals to health
care workers have a listen we were
looking for a way to feed the nurses
because Chris and I have been talking
about this since you know March 17th we
need to we need to get to the hospitals
we want to give our time and our food to
feed the healthcare workers the
frontline workers how you know we just
didn't have a contact important way to
get the attention of somebody we could
make the call so while they weren't
quite able to figure it out themselves
they hooked up with an initiative on the
same wavelength
it's called sustain the line it connects
people who want to donate meals to
health care workers helping them and
helping restaurants stay afloat it's
already operating in a number of cities
across North America I'll tell you more
about it introduce you to a Canadian
behind the project and tell you how you
can help in our coronavirus the new
reality special later tonight Robin all
right Abigail thank you so much and you
can watch that Network special
coronavirus the new reality at 7:00 p.m.
tonight and every Sunday right here on
global Donna Friesen is host of that
special and she'll be back on the anchor
desk tomorrow that is global national
for this Sunday I'm Robin Gill thank you
for watching and good night
[Music]
you